"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
TO BATTEN DOWN THE HATCHES
BECAUSE IS IT ABOUT TO GET
ROUGH.
THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING ROCKED
BY MORE BRUTAL POLL NUMBERS.
TRY TO GET INTO CAMPAIGN MODE
AND TRY TO AVOID MAKING THE
MIDTERMS ABOUT HIS JOB
PERFORMANCE BUT TIME TO BE
RUNNING OUT BECAUSE HIS APPROVAL
RATING IS STILL IN A NOSEDIVE
HITTING A NEW LOW OF JUST 39%
AND HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON STAGGERING
INFLATION.
AS FEARS AS MIDTERM ELECTION
LOSSES LOOM LOOM.
EVEN SOME IN THE MEDIA CHIMING
IN ON SOME OF THE SERIOUS
TROUBLES THAT DEMOCRATS FACE IN
NOVEMBER.
>> THEIR VIEWS ABOUT THE ECONOMY
HARD AND AROUND MAY.
DEMOCRATS ARE IN SOME SERIOUS
TROUBLE RIGHT NOW IN OUR MB
MSNBC POLL 60% OF THE COUNTRY
THINKS TO TO.
IN THE PAST HAVE SINGLED BIG
LOSSES FOR THE PARTY.
>> Dana: ALSO GETTING A
CELEBRITY CHECK FROM JEFF BEZOS.
CORPORATE TAX RATES TO SOARING
INFLATION AND TWEETING
ADMINISTRATION TRIED HARD TO
INJECT EVEN MORE STIMULUS INTO
AN ALREADY OVER HEATED
INFLATIONARY ECONOMY AND ONLY
MANAGED TO SAVE THEM FROM
THEMSELVES.
INFLATION IS A REGRESSIVE TAX
THAT MOST HURTS THE LEAST
ASPECT.
AT THIS DIRECTION DOESN'T HELP
THE COUNTRY AND TODAY
PETER DOOCY ASK ABOUT THAT VERY
ISSUE LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DOES RAISING TAXES ON
CORPORATIONS LOWER THE COST OF
GAS, THE COST OF FOOD FOR
EVERYDAY AMERICANS?
>> LOOK I THINK WE ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE WHO'VE DONE VERY WELL
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO CARE ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE TO SUPPORT A FAIR
TAX CODE THAT DOESN'T CHANGE OR
CHARGE MANUFACTURERS WORKERS,
COPS, THAT THE MOST FORTUNATE
PEOPLE IN OUR NATION AND NOT LET
THAT STAND IN THE WAY OF
REDUCING ENERGY COSTS AND
FIGHTING THIS PROBLEM.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
REALLY ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> Jesse: THAT'S THE ONLY PART
OF THE DAY THAT I SAW.
>> Dana: IT'S THE FIRST DAY.
>> Jesse: I HOPE SHE GETS
BETTER THAN THAT BECAUSE READING
EVERYONE CAN READ.
THIS NBC NEWS POLL WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT NBC.
THIS IS LIKE THE INSIDE THE
BELTWAY PRISTINE PEACOCK POLL
EVERYONE PUTS IT UP ON SUNDAY
MORNING MEET THE PRESS.
THAT IS REALLY SCARY AT 39%.
IT'S ALMOST 75% IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, ANOTHER POLL HAD 80%
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION HAS BEEN
THAT BAD SINCE RIGHT AFTER
JANUARY 6 AND THE IMPEACHMENT?
THAT'S PRETTY STARTLING NUMBERS.
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT HE IS
INSTRUCTING TO GET TOUGH FOR THE
MIDTERMS, NO HE'S NOT.
THEY ARE INSTRUCTING JOE BIDEN
TO GET TOUGH.
HE HAS A PUPPET AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT WHY IS THAT?
HE CAME IN WITH ALL THIS
POLITICAL CAPITAL.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
HEALER, BUT NOW THE PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE IT'S BEEN FALSE
ADVERTISING.
HE HASN'T HEALED ANYTHING
EVERYTHING IS GOTTEN WORSE HE'S
LIKE THE DOCTOR YOU GO IN AND
YOU LIKE HERDS AND HE SAYS PUT
SOME CREAM ON IT AND YOU LIKE
FALLS OFF.
IT IS GOTTEN WORSE AT LEAST
DONALD TRUMP YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
WERE GETTING WHEN YOU PUT THEM
IN OFFICE.
YOU'RE GETTING UP A FEISTY
RABBLE-ROUSER.
IT FEELS LIKE THIRD WORLD VIBES.
HIGH CRIME, HIGH INFLATION, YOU
CAN'T GET STUFF THEIR SHORTAGES
AND ANTI-SHELVES.
THIS IS NOT THE AMERICA THAT
PEOPLE LOVE AND RESPECT.
NOW, IF YOU GO IN AND YOU BLOW
UP THE BORDER AND THE DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY WITH VACCINATION
MANDATES AND THEN SCRUB
AFGHANISTAN, EVERYONE IS TO BE
LIKE WHOA, WHOA, WHAT IS GOING
ON?
WHEN YOU ADD TO THAT LACK OF
VISION HE DIDN'T SEE TWO COVID
WAVES COMING.
YOU'RE SEEING A GUY THAT SHE WAS
HAPLESS AS A LEADER AND YOU CAN
EITHER BE A POOR LEADER AND A
GOOD POLITICIAN OR A POOR
POLITICIAN AND A GOOD LEADER.
JOE BIDEN IS BAD AT BOTH AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOT REALIZE
THAT.
>> Dana: I WANT ABOUT THIS
IDEA THAT HE'S NOW GETTING HIS
STAFF IN A CAMPAIGN MODE BECAUSE
HER MEMBER IT WAS EARLY ON WHEN
THE GEORGIA VOTING LAW WAS
PASSED IN MEMBER HE CALLED
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED.
THE CAMPAIGNING NEVER REALLY
STOPPED ON EITHER SIDE.
>> Greg: I LIKE THEM TO BE IN
CAMPAIGN MODE ALL THE TIME.
[LAUGHS]
I WISH THEY WORKED AS HARD ON
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE FACED THAT
THEY WORK WHEN THEY FEAR THAT
THERE TO LOSE POWER.
GENERALLY PEOPLE IN AMERICA
DON'T HAVE CAMPAIGN MODES THAT'S
CALLED WORK RIGHT?
IF OUR JOB WAS TO CARE ABOUT
CRIME AND THE POLICE AND
INFLATION OF THE BORDER THESE
ARE THINGS THAT YOU WOULD CARE
ABOUT YEAR-ROUND AS OPPOSED TO
SIX MONTHS PRIOR TO A MIDTERM.
I THINK THAT MOST POLITICAL
LEADERS IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY WERE FORCED
TO CAMPAIGN YEAR-ROUND RIGHT?
BECAUSE WE HAVE A JOB RIGHT?
WE JUST DON'T GET A JOB AND WU
WERE IN, YET THE PROVE YOURSELF
EVERY DAY.
WHETHER IT'S SALES, OR'S
CUSTOMER SERVICE YOU'VE JOB
REVIEWS, BOSSES, DEADLINES.
ONCE POLITICIANS WIN AN ELECTION
IS LIKE THEY STOP WORKING.
THEY GET IN AND THEN THEY
UNROLLED HER SLEEVES I THINK
THAT'S WHY DONALD TRUMP WAS SO
UNUSUAL AND SO HATED BECAUSE HE
WAS IN WORK MODE.
HE WAS IN CAMPAIGN MODE ALL THE
TIME AND PEOPLE WERE LIKE...
IT'S EXHAUSTING.
THERE ARE ALWAYS POLITICAL SOLO
PROBLEMS DON'T EXIST UNTIL THEY
BECOME POLITICAL AND THEN
THEY'RE ILL-EQUIPPED TO FIX THEM
BECAUSE ARE NOT USED TO FIXING
PROBLEMS.
ONLY CAUSING THEM.
>> Dana: WHAT HE THINK OF
AMERICANS WHEN THEY SAY 75% OF
AMERICANS SAY THAT THE COUNTRY'S
GOING TO THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD
BIPARTISANSHIP RIGHT THERE.
75%.
>> Judge Jeanine: I NEVER
THOUGHT OF IT LIKE THAT.
WHAT YOU HAVE WHEN YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT A COMMANDER IN CHIEF
WHO CAN'T SEE THINGS WHEN THEIR
RIGHT BEFORE HIS VERY EYES?
JESSE YOU SAID HE DIDN'T SEE
COVERT COMING AND INFLATION
COMING.
DONALD TRUMP TOLD US THAT
INFLATION WAS COMING.
DONALD TRUMP TOLD US THAT THE
PRICES WERE GOING UP AND NOW SIX
MONTHS PRIOR TO A MIDTERM HE
DECIDES WILL G WE BETTER GET
INTO CAMPAIGN MODE.
NO, THE TRUTH IS YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DO ANYTHING TO GET INTO
IT OR TO GET OUT OF IT.
SO WHAT ARE THEY DUE?
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO TALK ABOUT
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED SO THEY PICK ON THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY SAY YOU KNOW WHAT, THOSE
REPUBLICANS ARE TERRIBLE AND
THEY THINK THAT WERE STUPID.
IF THEY PULL THE RUG OVER OUR
EYES WHILE THEY WERE REALLY
TERRIBLE.
INFLATION WAS 2%, NOTES 8.3.
THEY DID THINK THAT WERE JUST
STUPID ENOUGH TO BUY WHAT WERE
SELLING AND WERE BEYOND THAT
WERE ABSOLUTELY BEYOND THAT.
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE ANGUISHING
AND THEY ARE HURTING THEIR
HURTING FOR BABY FORMULA, HE
KNEW THAT WAS COMING AND HE DID
NOTHING ABOUT IT.
HELPING HER HUMAN SERVICES.
AND THEN AFGHANISTAN HE KNEW
THAT WE HAD TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN IT WAS THE WORST GET
OUT OF THE COUNTRY WE'VE EVER
SEEN.
HE SHOULD'VE TAKEN THE WEAPONS
THAT HE LEFT THERE AND GIVEN
THEM THE UKRAINIANS WOULD BE
BETTER OFF.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IS HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THE FAR LEFT SO IN SOME
WAYS THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
CAMPAIGNING INTERNALLY FOR A
LONG TIME BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THEY ARE BASICALLY HELPING
PROTECT THEM FROM BAD VOTES, BUT
THEY STILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO
DRIVE THAT MESSAGING TO THE
LEFT.
BE FIVE IF THEY DRIVE FOR TITLE
42 TO BE ABOLISHED A WEEK FROM
TODAY THEY WILL HAVE HELPED
DESTROYED THE JOE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY.
>> Geraldo: I THINK TO BE A
MONUMENTAL DIMENSION AND THE
REVERBERATIONS MIGHT RESULT IN A
ROWDY NOVEMBER AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY 2024.
I THINK WITH INFLATION AND
IMMIGRATION, WITH CRIME, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOOMED EXCEPT FOR
ONE THING.
THIS LEAK AND THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE ABORTION DECISION HAS
CHANGED THE POLITICAL CALCULUS
IN THIS COUNTRY AND I THINK WE
DON'T ADDRESS IT WE DON'T DEAL
WITH IT IN A STRAIGHTFORWARD WAY
BECAUSE I SEE IT ALREADY IN
LITTLE CLEVELAND OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THOUSANDS TURNED OUT IN HUNDREDS
OF PLACES AROUND THE COUNTRY, I
THINK WITH THE SUPREME COURT HAS
DONE IS IGNITE THE SUBURBS AND
THEY COULD CHANGE THE ENTIRE
DYNAMIC OF THE ELECTION DESPITE
INFLATION AND IMMIGRATION AND
CRIME IN UKRAINE AND SO FORTH.
IT IS SO EMOTIONALLY BROUGHT